encuentra el producto 2 x + 8 x 2 x 8
esto básicamente es una multiplicación
de binomios así que podríamos resolverla
utilizando el método foil o la propiedad
distributiva sin embargo creo que el
punto del problema es ver si podemos
reconocer un patrón si podemos reconocer
que este producto es de la forma más b a
b por a menos b
- b y en efecto lo es verdad si hay 2x y
bs 8 entonces aquí tenemos a más b y
aquí tenemos a menos b de hummer
desarrollar esto se acaba utilizando la
propiedad distributiva y luego lo que
nos queda lo aplicamos para este vale
entonces voy a distribuir este a más b
con este a y luego con este ente menos b
podríamos hacer lo mismo con este y
obtener la respuesta más rápido pero lo
voy a hacer un poco más en general para
que el patrón sea más claro entonces a
mars b por a
por eso queremos restar a b a b por ver
si esté más por este menos se hace menos
y nos queda a b por ve muy bien ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es volver a usar la
propiedad distributiva pero ahora así
que se distribuya sobre estos dos y que
este vez se distribuya sobre estos dos
nos queda ahora es cuadrada luego más
por b que es b luego menos b por a que
también es a b a b y menos menos b por b
que es b cuadrada simplificando podemos
cancelar este con este porque son
iguales pero éste tiene signo menos y
nos queda a cuadrada menos b cuadrada
entonces ahí está el patrón si tenemos
la suma de dos números y la
multiplicamos por la resta de esos
mismos dos números entonces nos queda el
primero al cuadrado menos el segundo al
cuadrado muy bien ahora sí vamos a
aplicar esto que acabamos de descubrir
en este problema donde dijimos que 12
quisiera
no sé si tenemos a más y 8 es b b
entonces esté a menos vez entonces que
nos quedaría pues simplemente hay que
aplicar directamente la fórmula nos
queda a cuadrada o sea 2 x al cuadrado
menos b cuadrados y al menos 8 al
cuadrado y esto a cuánto es iguales 2 x
al cuadrado es 4 x al cuadrado y 8 al
cuadrado es 64 entonces queda 4 x al
cuadrado menos 64